like you also have a lot of uh
continuous optimizers and so this is
like it's a talk about a discrete
optimization problem which will be the
Nash social welfare and the weighted n
social welfare but uh I will actually it
won't be a typical talk I would
typically give it I'll only give you a
series of mathematical programs there
will not be any algorithms on it but the
claims that these M programs are
inherent for uh some algorithms okay um
good uh I'll talk about a couple of
joint Works more recent with uh uh Adam
Brown who's a jch adti l who was a jite
tech and now moved to Yale and mad Sudan
Fu and CMU and some also older work with
Nima nari from Stanford sharan and udab
and a mean Sai also from Stanford uh
okay good so let me just Define you what
the problems are so let me start first
by the Nash social welfare um the
problems as follows I'm given a set of a
n agents and a set of M Goods think of
the number of goods be more than the
number of agents and for each agent and
each good you have a certain value non-
negative value how much they value that
good this agent values that good and our
goal is to assign these Goods to these
agents to maximize a certain objective
and the objective you're going to say is
for each agent if I give them a bundle
they'll just add up the values so it's
ative valuation for each agent but then
every agent gets a certain value from
their bundle of the items that they
receive question is how am I going to
combine these values I'm just going to
take the geometric mean of them okay so
this is called a Nas social welfare
objective uh
it's been classically studied for more
in the setting of divisible Goods okay
we are going to mainly focus on like
where we find assignment but when you're
divisible Goods you can actually give a
fraction of some this item to this
person and another some other fraction
to that more formally you have to find
XI JS which is a fraction of item J that
you get to agent I and then the
valuation and so of course the
constraint would be to that every item
you can only use total fractions have to
add up to one and this will be the
valuation because it's still additive if
I give you half item uh then you your
value objective is half the total value
that you get from the unit item and then
again you do the geometric mean uh this
actually this one has been classically
studied goes back to the work of Nash
and Nash bargaining he actually took a
very exatic approach he said let me I
don't care about any objective let me
ask the following problem I have a for
some very natural objectives oh like
axioms that any allocation rule must
satisfy these four aums and what are the
possible like objectives that I wouldn't
want to optimize to obtain satisfy all
those axium and he proved that the only
unique one is this objective okay I
won't go into what those aums are but
the couple of them are very nice
properties about this that a scale free
every player can tell their own
valuation in their units okay whatever
your your units could be dollars or
whatever like yeah so it's completely
scale free is just a thought to see like
I can tell in my units you tell in your
units there is no going to be comparison
between us uh both of them and the other
thing is nicely combines efficiency and
fairness
um there could be a a very nice paper by
kianis at all which basically showed
that even in the the the discrete
setting there's unreasonable fairness of
Nash social welfare that's a title of
the very nice title of the paper of
course uh building on some older titles
but yes uh it I won't into detail but it
is the the the this objective wants you
to give items to players who value that
item quite a lot as well as won't force
you to basically make somebody uh not
getting any items so it does combine
both of them good so that's the N social
welfare objective uh I'll come to this
divisible one bit more we'll talk a bit
more about that as well so let me get
tell you the more General problem as
well which is the weighted Nash social
welfare problem actually after Nash's
work there was a lot of uh Works which
followed by looking at his axium and
asking whether they are the right set of
axium or can you change them then one of
them was Works was by kalai and he
dropped what is known as the Symmetry
axium the Symmetry AUM was that if you
permute the players you still uh the
your allocation Ru should not depend on
the name of the player in some sense and
if you drop that uh then kalai showed
that the only objectives which satisfy
the remaining axioms are what are known
as weit natural social welfare
objectives which are defined as follows
I'm additionally for each player I'm
going to give you a weight which add up
to one so the sum of the weights will
add up to one non- negative weights and
this time you will take the product of
of the value the value of the bundle for
player I to the power of
w so if the weights were all equal 1 / n
we will exactly get the geometric mean
otherwise we getting some weighted mean
uh weighted geometric mean of
them
good that's so these are the two
problems I will solve and uh uh both
these problems are NP and actually
they're apx hard so we'll basically be
looking at approximation algorithms
except I'm not going to give you any
algorithms in the stock what the main of
the goal of the stock would be to
introduce you some convex and non-convex
relaxations for both these problems and
which will have some worst case
approximation guarantees for this you
will have to believe me a bit as well
but at least I'll I'll try to convince
you why they there exists some worst
case approximation guarantees and
something mainly you want to think about
it is if I want to just estimate the
value what you can get right I give you
instance of these problems and you want
to estimate me what's the value of the
objective the optimum solution right so
question is one way to estimate is to by
write some relaxation I solve that
relaxation and the value of it will be
my estimate okay so we will try to
understand how can we write that uh
write such
relaxations okay so the first one so
first first half of the talk I'll mainly
focus on the Nash social welfare and
then weighted one problem is clearly
more General so then we will piggyback
on the work that had be done for n
social welfare and come to the weighted
one right so I'll go back to the
standard n social welfare where there no
weights all the weights are 1 over
n good so how do you can do how do I
write the first relaxation well the
first relaxation is I allow you to
divide the items okay good so the in the
nas social welfare I you have you can't
divide items in players you have to give
every item to only one player but if I
allow you to divide it then you exactly
get a convex relaxation but of course
the objective function is not well
actually it is in that sense but if you
take a log then you can easily see it is
actually convex now you get a this is a
concave function you're maximizing so
you get a tractable relaxation okay so
good so I've just taken the objective
and taken a log of it okay so this is my
first uh crack at the problem and this
this is the relaxation which was studied
by Nash and actually it shows up in in
lots of settings basically yeah like if
if you look at uh uh many kind of
fairness uh uh uh regimes where like
even for example tcpip protocol and so
on these are the exactly the kind of
objectives actually which show up as
well over there okay but for our problem
actually this is a terrible relaxation
good why is it a terrible one for
example even if you have a single good
but two agents clearly then the the
optimum answer is zero but this like
I've taken a log but really if I like I
should take exponent again but if for
conx program actually we'll split the
item into both of them and both those
players will be happy because at least
got something right but I know there is
no feasible solution over here which
will get you a non-zero objective but
the conx program can get you that okay
and we are aiming for something which
are multiplicative approximations which
are not good okay so so such a setting
is really bad just to tell you and I'll
come to this there was a very nice paper
by Cole and cust cilis in 2015 who gave
the first constant Factor approximation
for the N social welfare right the
standard problem that we going to look
at I'll come to that but before that
I'll give you a slightly different
relaxation okay a stronger relaxation so
this bound is significantly can be
significantly higher than what the real
answer is right even if the real answer
is zero it can give you a non-zero
answer question is how do you get uh a
better bound so this so this was a work
that we did with anaran and
Sai good so this really like it's a nice
one what I've done is uh now I'm going
to think of my objective as a polinomial
okay and the way what we're going to do
is this is my complex program I'm
maximizing over all fractional
allocations as we were doing before so
this thing has not changed except my
estimate if you give me a fraction
allocation what is my estimate for that
that's going to change earlier it was
just log of submission XI viig I summed
up of that now I'm allowing you to do
scale the values for the items okay so
think of Ys as a certain scaling y's are
non- negative we'll think about what
those scalings are so every item now I
will scale it okay it's value from VI to
V * YJ that's all what you should think
about it and I'm going to take a minimum
over all possible scalings but of course
what are my feasible scalings my
feasible scalings will be the following
that if I take a product of any n items
their scaling scaling factors should be
at least one
what is the
solution X is what you're optimizing
over for y just one no Y is your minimum
right so if y were one then you're back
to the original program which we saw
before so that's not a good idea you
should possibly put a different Y in
that sense because because I'm going to
take a Min over y so for a f fixed X I'm
going to take my best bound right which
is a Min over y I'm not integ solution
so there is no integer solution right
because it's think of it that way for a
fixed X okay good so what we should
first see is why is this even a
relaxation okay that this is a
relaxation and those are the kind of the
only proofs I will show you that the
convex programs I'm going to write
firstly I haven't even show you this is
convex okay but uh I think maybe Millan
St might actually already seeing you
that it is actually a uh there is some
nice convexity overhead
yesing something the WIS are on
the on the products or on the players on
on items so I don't to get rid of your
previous integrality Gap because if I
only have one then I'm going to set that
y1 to one and I it's G so good good good
because no because this is saying for
any subset of that particular size there
then I will put y to be zero actually
because there's no subset of size two
over there so so that way I'll take it
to zero okay so that's a like a extreme
case but really my constraint is only
for subset of size to so in that case I
don't they don't have any constraint
actually for that particular case
then so because then I will basically
set YJ to be zero so so I'll just take
the scaling factor to zero over that
case maybe I should have made a better
example but okay let's just try to
understand why is this even a relaxation
okay good why is this a relaxation so
let's say what do I need to show you
about relaxation if I pick a integral
solution like basically this objective
value should be bigger than the value of
that integral solution any integral
solution right so for any integral
solution Sigma let's say it's assignment
X I will set to be the indicator Vector
for that assignment right XI J to be one
if Sigma is telling you to assign that
good to that item right item J2 play
good so let's just plug that X and I'm
going to say show you that this minimum
value will be at least the value of that
integer assignment value okay why is
that the case so let's just I'm going to
take the Min overall Y and I'm going to
think of it like write it this way ah I
took the sum inside the log okay so
because I really want to think of this
as a polinomial in y okay the sum I took
a product so what is this polinomial
these are linear terms how many of them
there n of them one for each player so
this is a degree n polinomial correct
there's a degree n polinomial in M
variables or number of uh items but it's
a multi-linear polinomial now right
because each item will only be assigned
to one player it cannot appear in two
different linear terms okay so if I
expand it out I'll only get multi-linear
terms of what degree will degree exactly
n and my straint says that all of these
terms were must be at least one so I can
say that this is at least as if these
terms were not there right so these y
variables really like if they were all
one it's clearly a relaxation is what we
had before but by putting these
constraints on Q it's behaving as if
they're all one but of of course my
constraints are only on their products
right so this will be exactly as it's
this term will behave exactly as what I
wanted to be so it's a relaxation okay
good yeah so the and I really need to
show for every y it works not for a
fixed y right yes good actually and this
this is a very good uh uh bound like you
can look at because if we in log space
if I look at the optimum value it's a
relaxation so the first inequality is
that the convex programming value this
value is bigger than the logarithmic of
my Optimum value and you can show it's
within because I'm looking at the
multiplicative approximation so in the
log scale it should be additive so in
the additive I only lose something like
a log of e so it's get you e
approximation so uh this proof okay we
not going to do because this really
relies on algorithms but really there
are some inequalities on stable
polinomial that's what is needed for
proving this
result okay questions yes sorry so just
to understand there an e to the N
approximation of the no no no you
have yes exactly yes so actually I'm not
going over there but actually this e to
the N you can think over way is the same
one that comes for gwi's Bound for
permanence so and there is a
relationship ship to that as well over
here I'm not like yeah okay but maybe
that's a different talk good so let's
keep going uh like yeah okay so there is
a different work which I promised you
like Cole and gistics really they didn't
really write explicit conx program but
which was followed up by uh Cole at all
uh they wrote a different conx program
okay so this is even weirder okay and at
least only now I would say at least I
have some understanding maybe hopefully
I'll try to get across so they you
looked at the classic one like the basic
one let's go back to our basic one which
is bad we know this is a bad con program
but actually this one there's a very
nice work which shows that this is
equivalent to a conx program given by
SMF for a different problem for market
equilibrium and I'll explain what that
is but the equivalence really is byas
via some Market problem in particular
this this program you can reformulate it
as ice and burn Gale market equilibrium
problem and for which this is another
conx program which is known okay so what
is this do doing let's just see so B
variables are not assignment variables
what are my constraints on B they are
saying think of it this way every player
gets $1 of budget which they can use to
buy different items so that's what this
constraint is right it's not that every
item being assigned here every item is
being assigned fractionally so the sum
is over the constraint is over for the
items here my constraint is over every
uh player every player gets one and for
every possible assignment I have a
certain objective which is like a very
inro kind of objective first term is a
linear term but the second term is a
nonlinear term which is a very entropy
kind of objective I won't go into detail
where this comes from but basically this
is a a complex program that is known
these are equivalent well that doesn't
bias anything but at least let me try to
convince you that there is a it's a
relaxation again okay so why is so for
example what is a feasible B right what
is a feasible B the feasible for
integral assignment for integral
assignment the B that you set it to be
well if you don't give item J to player
I then you set it to zero otherwise you
give it what fraction of value displayer
gets from this item okay so VI J divid
by Vi where VI is the sum of all the
values that this get right this a
fraction of the value this player gets
from this item so clearly if I sum for
any player all the values that he gets
from all the items that he's assigned
this will sum up to one so that's a
constraint and if you plug this thing
this uh assignment in the value you will
exactly get the log of the N social
welfare objective right that's just a
calculation I won't do it but you can
believe me that is true
okay good so we have also got one more
nice relaxation but we know these are
equivalent so this one was crappy so
will this be right for our discrete
problem right so that's that doesn't
help us but now we can strengthen this
okay and that's what was done by Co at
all what they said was the constraint
they will add
is which is what they call the spended
restricted conx program is that for
every good the sum of the the BS which
will add up to a good will be no more
than one okay and this will still remain
a relaxation why is that the case well
in the integral solution for a good only
one B was non zero it was for the the I
for which this item was assigned and
what was that well it was a
fraction of value that this item was
providing to that player clearly that
fraction is no more than one and only
one of them was non zero so this
constraint is always satisfying so
clearly this is a strend like this is a
still a valid relaxation and it's it's a
string and uh uh these people basic Ally
show that actually this is a very good
conx program it gives you a bound within
like it's a relaxation that's a first
inequality and it gives you a bound
within a factor of two okay at least
like in the lock space so it's additive
to I won't prove it uh I will let I'll
just convince you why intuitively such a
proof will be true is that the support
of this is actually a forest so if I
look at only the BS which are nonzero
and look at on the graph those my graph
is a bipartite graph right players
versus items that actually will is a a
forest
okay let me convince you why that is
true well the objective is convex in
terms of some sense you shouldn't expect
s spacity but then you as do the
following thing let you say this is a
linear term for the nonlinear term
whatever is inside the log let me
actually fix it whatever it is you give
me optimal solution B Star let me fix
this quantity okay that's one constraint
for each player which is the same
quantity as over here and once you fix
that what you get is just assignment LP
okay and we know any extreme Point
solution to assignment l p is actually
will be a forest and uh then you can
look at David's book to figure out how
to convert this into integral solution
it's not much different than some of the
things that he does for some scheduling
problems okay but like yeah but uh what
you get is basically a factor two okay
just to so now at least we've done n
social welfare I'll move on to the
weighted one strictly contained in your
relaxation we come to that as well okay
good yeah so so yes so yeah you're going
for my punch line but we we'll come to
that
later so good so the first we started
with these three of them right the
assignment conx program the isenberg
Gale conx program in the SM right we I
didn't give you the Iber Gale but
basically more or less so these are all
poor approximation they gave poor bounds
we sended an assignment to this
polinomial one and then we send in the
SM one to the spended restricted one
well whatever the call it all did and
both of these gives you constant Factor
approximations good so that's how and
now I want to move to the weighted
weighted version of the problem
good so the weighted one as we just said
this over over ahead that's what the
main part of this I wanted to go so just
recall you also have weights which sum
up to one okay
good so what you want to do is of course
look at these coners programs and
generalize them to the weighted version
okay so that's what we
do okay good so the first thing you do
is we go to the the spended restricted
one and generalize it what we do is
basically the first KN thing you would
want to do is plug in the weight
wherever you saw one over n replace one
n by a wi okay and you do that you get
exactly what this is okay and it it
doesn't like yeah so your objective this
had one over n in the linear term and
then you had the entropy term where you
had a one/ n so I just plugged in the W
over there and it turns out this is
actually your relaxation it requires
some care but it actually it's not too
much more difficult and you run the same
argument that the support is a forest
you can round it all of those arguments
a bit more involved but they work out
actually your constant factors are a bit
worse it's a relaxation and it's not
much worse okay and support is still
remains still a tree the same arguments
still work out problem now is the
following thing this is not a convex
program okay which is crazy actually
like this is this function is convex
only if the wi are all equal okay for a
general wi this is not convex it almost
like yeah yeah okay I couldn't believe
when I worked out the calculation but
that is actually true so this is not
convex but you know if I give if you I
can actually fraction given a a fraction
solution I can actually round it very
well the rounding algorithms I can
generalize over there right whatever
they were we didn't over there so
question is what do we do now what we
did was
uh we wrote a different program right so
this is the conx non-convex program I'm
I'm going to write you a different one
and maybe I'll try to give you some like
it'll almost look crazier but I'll try
to get into the mystery a bit more so
I'll change my objective I'll basically
add two KL diverges KL Divergence terms
one is think of the weight Vector as a
probability distribution and I'm going
to take its scale Divergence with the
uniform distribution right this is a
both distributions over players then I
will also take two distributions given a
fixed B two distributions over the items
okay which are the following okay I
won't go into the detail in interest of
time and I'll just basically to my
non-convex term I add this and subtract
this and low behold this function is
actually a conve one now I maybe it
might look mysterious to you this is a
convex relaxation and good and so now if
you stay at it we are actually have a
very like at least approximation why
because these two object this term is
non-
negative sorry like this K Divergence
are non- negative so I I this term I can
drop how much worse I'm getting is
exactly the K Divergence between my
weight vector and the uniform
distribution okay so that's what my
approximation would be my approximation
would be basically the k diverg times
some constant for
fact good so in the interest of time let
me just quickly say that basically this
convex program will give you a pomal
time uh approximation which depends on
the K Divergence between the weight
vector and the uniform
distribution okay maybe I might have
gone too fast question is how do I even
write this conx program right okay and
and that maybe that's what I'll just
tell you quickly and then I will end uh
so the way to do it is the follows
recall like basically what we have done
so far is we looked at the spended
restricted conx program for the weighted
version I I wrote down a non spended
restricted non-convex program and some
these entropy kind of terms the scale
diverence term added and wrote These
convex programs over over here as well
okay so question is how did we get these
this one this convex program the first
thing we not is what uh Santos was
saying was what are the relationship
between those two conx program for the
symmetric version actually they're both
equivalent that's the first thing we
showed was that the pomal one as well as
the spended restricted one they are
actually equivalent for in the case of
when you have the UN like the standard n
social welfare problem and the pomal one
actually we can generalize very easily
and it still remains convex okay and
then you ask yourself you get a pomal
optimization problem which is convex and
what is it equivalent to now in the
weighted setting it turns out to be
exactly this one and here we know in
this in this view in the the spended
spended restricted view we can convert
it into integral solution because of
nice properties but but that's basically
what is happening okay I won't I want
don't have so much time like now but but
basically the the this was a convex
program pomal one that I showed you was
a relaxation for the nass social welfare
this is the one for the weighted one
here you plug in the weights at
appropriate places okay and stare at it
actually I never showed you this was
convex all right I never showed you this
is convex actually and you should be bit
careful in assuming it's convex because
I in X this function has to be log like
it has to be con concave in in X because
I'm maximizing in y it has to be convex
actually in y it is not convex my
constraints are not linear in y in you
actually have to go to log of Y entry
wise and then actually becomes convex or
uh you can like appeal to melan talk and
basically you will get geodesic
convexity in y as well that's another
way to view it as well okay but that's
that's basically to fill the picture
that's where we it is so right and now
you will basically Le this is a picture
I I want you to keep in mind if at all
there are a lot of these convex programs
but some of them nicely generalized to
remain convex the other ones but
sometimes you to round it actually you
need a non-convex formulation right to
get integer Solution that's why we we
really used it okay the bounce we only
get right now is only in exponential in
the K
Divergence so just to conclude basically
I just give you uh results for n social
welfare and we n social welfare I mainly
focused on
uh convex and nonconvex mathematical
programs there are other approaches as
well uh although I want to say they are
really inherently using the same convex
programs at the at the back but
basically work but work by Gus Le V
sorry
apologies WRA they wrote a series of
papers uh and some of these Works
actually work also in slightly more
general settings actually significantly
more general settings of valuation
functions not additive but some Moder
and so on uh the best approximation
factor for Nash social welfare in
additive setting is due to Burman
chrishan Swami and V they give a
combinatorial algorithm but intuitively
I want to still say like there some
convex programs are still underlying
them as well but the main one question
at least for Ved n social welfare is is
there a constant Factor approximation we
still don't
know the other one actually is a is
something that bothered us quite a lot
and maybe like there a lot of experts in
this room who can say tell us more
actually what is like solvability of a
non-convex formulation of course that's
hard I don't want to solve it exactly
okay at least get me a local Optima okay
I don't care about local Optima just get
me a kkt point okay actually even just
getting a kkt point in pomal time it's
not clear to me how I would do and then
I like yeah and uh I was just talking to
some people and they pointed me to this
paper actually Computing a kkd point is
actually CLS complete as well in general
of course the natural question would be
like yeah when can one characterize give
conditions when can you find a kkd point
in poal time under what conditions at
least yeah like and B can capture some
of these like some of these or or other
nonlinear uh non-convex programs I just
don't know exactly what the algorithm
would be for that as
well and poml I I really mean palom as
in poml in the bit size right bit bit
complexity fine but that's what I want
to say thank
[Applause]
you thank you very interesting talk I
think in the interest of time we're just
going to to go to the the next talk and
we can have questions
[Applause]
offline